[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know modeling is a lot of fun when
you traveling experience different
cultures and people in countries and it
is really a lot of fun whether it comes
a time when you just miss home
you miss those unique things from home
so for me from South Africa it's been
five months since I since I've seen my
wife and my dog and my family and it is
time to go home
so I'm packed I'm ready to go solicitor
[Music]
falls down and you have taken all you
care to turn
[Music]
you have saucepot you
[Music]
and the tears in our eyes tear the
traces of time
until we're even
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and together
and the seasons they come the stillness
search
[Music]
hey guys so I've been here in South
Africa for a couple of weeks as you can
see of the beard and I thought okay it's
time that I really introduce you guys to
our dog toga wiki - how old is he
almost three years old yeah let me show
you what he can do
[Music]
okay
[Music]
that's right I say bye anyway
okay
okay
[Music]
like wait this this can stop
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
Ricky's Ricky's freaky who I am
was it good what
[Music]
[Music]
whoo okay so now you guys know a little
bit more about toga
but unfortunately it's summer here in
South Africa and he is super hot so
we're gonna have to take him and shave
you hey white tiger
bye bye bye Toby
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa oh my goodness
toga but I don't forget the scene Wow
[Music]
right
[Music]
see
[Music]
[Music]
get Jack
[Music]
all right guys now you've seen tugga he
looks very different when he's shaved
right but yeah this is the family it's
me Nikita Doge over here you've seen
Nikita's mom as well but man this guy
gives us so much joy yeah and I know we
are mad and crazy about him so we should
probably start with a family soon yes
maybe soon yeah but yeah that's it let
us know in the comment section down
below if you have any pets and what do
you think about toga yeah thanks for
joining in guys in see in the next video
yes I Cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]